the media have an agenda and they're
making that agenda clear every single
day it's incredible it's on every topic
let me take a topic that really should
not be political for example let me take
the topic of what's going on with cover
19 so right now there's a big spike in
the number of cases that we have seen in
places like Texas Arizona California
right we've seen these big spikes really
across the Southwest and then in Florida
as well we've seen some spikes in
Georgia to see an increase in caseload
now normally when you are examining what
exactly is the factor leading to the
spike in caseload what you might want to
do is actually correlate the data so for
example if you are seeing a big spike in
caseload and it is coming eight to ten
weeks after the reopening maybe just
maybe it's not the reopening that is
causing this maybe just maybe the most
significant factor you might pause it
might be something like are people
spending lots of time indoors they're
conditioning to get so hot down south
that everybody went in their houses or
went out to public places went to
restaurants and instead of eating
outdoors
they ate indoors instead of hanging out
with their friends on the beach it was
too hot they went inside and they hung
out at a bar right wouldn't that be a
factor that you would spend more time on
and in fact the data tends to support
this suggestion because if you actually
look at many of the states that reopened
at the same time for example Colorado
and Georgia if had wildly varying
caseloads so Colorado reopened literally
the same day I believe the same week for
sure
as Georgia and got no attention for it
because of course the governor of
Colorado is a Democrat and the governor
of Georgia is a Republican and so
Georgia was gonna be the place where
everyone's eyes right everyone's gonna
die in Georgia and Colorado doesn't
exist right stops existing the minute
that they did the same thing as Georgia
well Georgia since the since the
reopening it has now been nearly three
months since the reopening in Georgia
according to the New York Times they
have started to experience an uptick in
cases right there are about two hundred
and forty five percent in cases which is
a significant uptick in the number of
cases and they're starting to see more
people hospitalized and more people or
going to ice use now is it an incredibly
massive number of people or doing this
it's not it's not thousands of people
it's not several hundred people who are
dying in ICUs in Georgia right now the
town's a death toll in Georgia is still
below a hundred last time I checked okay
but with all of that said they are
seeing a spike but you know who's not
seeing a spike and opened at the exact
same time is Colorado
a Colorado is not seeing a spike
Colorado is down 41% according to the
New York Times in average daily cases so
what the hell is going on we don't know
what the hell is going on
the answer is probably a Colorado in the
summertime is quite nice and Georgia in
the summertime is sweltering and so
people in Georgia are going indoors and
they are hanging out in crowded places
indoors with lots of air conditioning
that is the most likely scenario here
that is the that is the probable
rationale for why we are seeing all of
this happening is it or at least it's a
much better rationale than the reopening
because the reopening really does not in
any way reflect the the sort of delayed
statistics that we are currently seeing
by the way the actual statistic on daily
new deaths in Georgia not only well
below 100
well well below hundred like the low 30
daily deaths in Georgia all of last week
I think yesterday it was it was 8 they
day before that it was 23 according to
world ometer is these mass spike that
you're singing cases is not correlated
with mass mass deaths in Georgia you're
seeing increased deaths more so not in
Georgia more so in in Florida more so in
Texas more so in California where you're
seeing over 100 daily deaths in places
like that so is it the reopening
according to the media it is the
reopening and this is where you see the
masks absolutely coming off so the the
New York Times ran a piece called the
u.s. surge is being driven largely by
states that move to reopen early and
then they have a chart and shows places
like Florida Arizona South Carolina
Texas Georgia highlighted on this chart
right because those are all the places
that reopened early a few places that
are not highlighted on the chart our
places like California that has also
seen a spike in fact a spike that is
similarly sized to Georgia's but they're
not highlight why aren't they
highlighted the reason they're not
highlighted because oh I didn't really
reopen well they never reopened right
California has not been reopened very
long at all and they are seeing a spike
as big as Georgia's after a shorter
period of time so it doesn't it doesn't
help the narrative the media are trying
to push that it's the evil Republican
states that are causing all this and the
way that you know how corrupt the media
are on all this is that the same chart
from the New York Times highlights New
York so it shows Florida Plus 1393
percent in daily Hoffa in daily cases in
daily identified cases Arizona of 858
percent in daily identify
cases by the way largely in border areas
there is a serious issue with people who
are coming across the border
specifically to go to American hospitals
because of the hot because the infection
rate in Mexico right now is
extraordinarily high and then it shows
New York you are down 52 percent what
did they do right
what could New York have possibly done
right okay the actual answer what's in
New York to right everyone died that's
the actual answer okay the reason it's
incredible to watch the media retcon
this whole thing in real time it's
unbelievable actually I mean like
there's a tweet that was put out scott
Gottlieb who's been a guest on my Sunday
special he suggested the u.s. approach
on COBIT is A Tale of Two Cities some
states like Connecticut New York
Massachusetts start to crush the virus
sound like Florida Texas in Arizona
sought the Swedish model and tried to
manage spreads the less vulnerable
without a more uniform US approach will
be hard for either strategy to work okay
from just that tweet you would think
that there were some states that
attempted to crush the virus and there
are some states that sought to manage
the spread and they've ended up kind of
roughly equivalent or something like
that
right or even at the ones that are
crushing the virus they're now they're
crushing the virus man they've made it
they've crushed the virus and what
actually happened in northeastern states
like New York Massachusetts Connecticut
New Jersey the ones that one is a full
lockdown mode everyone died okay not
because of the lockdown
but because it was there early they
didn't know what to do with it they were
sending coded patients back into nursing
homes what half the patients who died in
these cases were nursing home patients
basically people who are in elderly or
assisted living facilities and let me
give you the actual stats on the
quote-unquote crushed the curve people
versus the maintained the spread people
because right now remember all focus in
the United States is on Texas Florida
Arizona right that's where all the focus
is right now all of it okay it is not
like there is some focus on New Jersey
or New York or by the way cases continue
to crop up in New York there's still
five hundred to a thousand daily cases
in New York that are happening every
single day and if you look at these
states where there's still mass levels
of death just gonna know New York still
ranks like numbers number six on this
chart New Jersey had over a hundred
deaths yesterday is anyone talking about
New Jersey in order of in order of
deaths yesterday it goes California
number one California 137 no one's
mentioned in California Florida number
two scouring the world on
New Jersey is number three so two of the
top three are blue states right but you
know one here at California and you
don't hear New Jersey New Jersey had
over 100 deaths yesterday Texas is
number four behind New Jersey and 102
Arizona is number five at 75 then New
York at 32 and Virginia which is now
blue at 32 and Pennsylvania which is now
blue at 31 right then you've got
Massachusetts which is blue at 25 hey
then you get down into Tennessee North
Carolina South Carolina okay then so
that list does not suggest that red
versus blue is the deciding factor here
right you're seeing it in red states and
resting in blue states you're seeing it
in lockdown states and you're seeing it
in non lockdown states what does this
actually suggest it suggests that when
the virus goes around it kills everybody
who's vulnerable and the only thing you
can really do is protect the vulnerable
that's really what it suggests and the
less time you can spend in confined
areas with people breathing from the
same air conditioning facilities the
better off you are that's all the
suggests it doesn't suggest even the
masking is the particularly effective
factor right may be masking works maybe
it doesn't maybe it slows the spread
maybe the evidence on this is actually
kind of mixed okay by the way the ego in
medical wisdom up until 2016 2017 is
that wearing masks prevent the spread of
flu for example well it's not supremely
effective so there's some evidence that
suggests sure it helps stop the spread
of this thing particularly if you're in
close quarters or not huge periods of
time but it is also true that a lot of
the particles do escape the mask and all
the rest of this sort of stuff so I
think that clarity here in what we don't
know is actually quite useful but the
media are attempting to drive a
narrative into the media are just being
dishonest about all of this stuff
all right the suggestion that lock downs
are the key and then we should reel Ock
down because lock downs are the key is
absolutely anti data okay there is not
enough data to support this perspective
let me give you the total deaths by
state okay total deaths by state because
remember we're told that some of these
states Texas Florida Arizona you're
doing it wrong you opened up too early
Georgia he did it you open up too early
New York New Jersey Massachusetts
connect it you watch it down guys
you were really solid on this stuff wait
until you hear the differential in
deaths in these days okay because but
that would suggest is I'm kind of not